[Music]  blah blah blah surveys let's go the  three words my sweetheart  likes to hear are my sweetheart Amy  you're the bee's knees are you hung the  moon the three words my sweetheart likes  to hear our emmy rossum wrote I love you  Justin Timberlake wrote I need you Joe  Biden wrote hey how are ya couldn't help  noticing how gar Stern pretty you've  been looking today  you've been the cream in my coffee for  as long as I can remember but today you  got something thanks for going and boy  I'll tell you it's ringing my bells  sweetheart when my sweetheart comes a  spoon in ukulele in hand this  Valentine's Day I'm getting my  sweetheart who's writing needs who's  writing sweetheart I want the writers  name Gordo was at you writing sweetheart  who is it  how was it you is it you my sweetheart  oh my god it's back to Patagonia with  you back to Patagonia get a lift from  Bohr Hayes on the way thank God if I  knew what country he was from I'd  insulting my sweetheart and I went down